you're the latest calls between former
President Obama and President Trump
hello you probably heard that mera lago
is the new Camp David I don't think
that's true
I mostly the Chinese president there
next month I forgot his name losing
things
no that's a bad day hello Abe Iraq what
do you want I want your opinion which
guy do you like better this one or this
one
Donald we're on the phone I can't see
what ties you're holding up Yeah right
sure you can I'm holding them up in
front of the microwave you like the red
one I am NOT spying on you through your
microwave vice what are you using
I hope it's that's a bidet that would be
gross Avery you have to help me out of a
jam which of your many jams is that
remember I said you were tapping my line
well they want me to submit proof you
did it by next week good luck with that
so full confession I can take this call
so you could just say hey president
Trump I Barack Obama have been
wiretapping your car of course I won't
say that say what exactly nice truck I'm
on fire back
did you see consumer confidence is at a
15-year high we're making America great
again okay Donald congratulations ever
since I was elected American consumers
are buying all sorts of things in record
numbers luggage
airline tickets cancers good though we
thought bomb shelters enter the present
status memorabilia
hello home surgery kick ski match
baseball bat with five wire wrapped
around the first to throw gets both
Bibles
how about mattresses TV with citizenship
alcohol
they're ready to hear your biology
anytime now I'm not going to apologize I
haven't done anything wrong you would
start a camera in my microwave a major
violation of privacy that's absolutely
ridiculous if I was going to install a
camera in your home it definitely
wouldn't be in the microwave that's
where I have my most intimate and
vulnerable moment what you're having sex
with the microwave are you serious it
was the waffle maker and it was just
sexual
[Applause]
you